y relève bonjour nous sommes en direct
ce mercredi matin pour faire un nouveau
point sur la guerre en ukraine puisque
aujourd'hui cela fait six mois que le
conflit a débuté et c'est aussi une
autre date symbolique puisque c'est la
date de l'aisne de l'anniversaire de
l'indépendance de l'ukraine pour parler
de ce sujet bien sûr chez avec alexis
faire chaque journaliste au figaro
adjoint du pôle actu bonjour alexis
bonjour un sens et avec vous intéresse
vous n'hésitez pas à tout cela il va
poser vos questions on y répond du mieux
qu'on peut comme d'habitude vous le
savez
alexis la première question on va
montrer la voie montrer ses cartes qui
sont faites par le service infographie
on les remercie d'ailleurs remontrer ses
cartes le conflit n'a pas beaucoup bougé
ces derniers mois non et j'ai envie de
dire on a fait des live depuis le 24
février je ne sais pas combien on en a
fait beaucoup mais ce qu on remarquera
c'est qu'on en fait aussi deux de moins
en moins ils sont plus en plus d'espacés
mais aussi parce que là la carte change
de moins en moins et vous dire les
choses très franchement la carte que
vous voyez là aujourd'hui elle est à
jour est bien là la carte d'il ya deux
mois était quasiment la même de manière
très brève il ya deux mouvements
principaux il ya l'offensive russe dans
le donbass menée dans l'extrême est de
l'ukraine ils ont pris le blast de
lougansk le plus à l'est est maintenant
il essaye de prendre l'intégralité le
blast de donetsk
et bien sur ce front là les russes
peinent à avancer cirque aujourd'hui
c'est d avancer de quelques même pas de
quelques kilomètres parfois de quelques
centaines de mètres à l'intérieur de
localités qui sont des localités pas par
ailleurs assez petit les villes qui sont
les qui sont un enjeu aujourd'hui pour
les russes c'est des villes comme bach
mouthe comme s'ils versent comme à
venise cas comme seul et d'ars et des
villes de moins de cent mille habitants
donc ça c'est que c'est quelque chose
d'important il ya une réduction de
l'échelle des conflits d'un point de vue
géographique et ça se voit sur la sur la
carte et l'autre le lot de points chauds
sur la sur la carte c'est la fameuse
contre-offensive d'été de l'ukraine dans
la région de kherson sur la rive droite
du nième donc à l'ouest d'une ligne être
là encore les ukrainiens l'annoncent
depuis en réalité quasiment des mois et
pour l'instant la ligne de front n'a pas
bougé donc on en est là aujourd'hui dans
une forme de de stagnation de la ligne
de front et qui pose une question
immédiate c'est ce qu'on est face à un
enlisement militaire mais je pense qu'on
en reparlera effectivement on peut
peut-être parler vu que ça fait quand
même six mois que ce conflit a débuté
ont peut-être parti ne part pas du début
parce qu'on voit sur cette carte toutes
les zones en bleu or elle qu' il ya eu
une attaque éclair de la russie qui a
voulu prendre très rapidement
de la place qui a envahi une grande
partie du territoire ukrainien au début
et qui finalement
partir ou dame en absolu mais en fait le
24 février donc il ya exactement six
mois
il ya l'ukraine a été envahie par la
russie sur trois fronts un front nord
depuis la biélorussie alliés de la
russie un front assez large
à l'est de l'ukraine surtout dans toute
la frontière avec la russie est en
réalité on allait du dombass
non dans le sud est jusqu'à
jusqu'à soumis au nord donc ça c'était
le front de l'est et puis avait un front
du sud qu'ils feront qu est le plus
avancé qui est parti de crime et la
crimée donc a été
récupéré par la russie en 2014 et
intégrée formellement au territoire
russe après un référendum qui viennent
on est n'est pas reconnue par la
communauté internationale
donc c'était vraiment un une invasion
quasiment complète de l'intégralité de
l'ukraine s'il n'y avait pas de fond de
l'ouest mais pour une raison évidente ce
cas pas de frontières possible avec la
avec la russie il ya eu des frappes le
le 24 février sur l'intégralité du
territoire les russes en réalité au
début se sont rapidement avancé et
notamment par le nord et par l'est ils
ont rapidement avancer vers kiev on se
souvient que tu acquiers accès
rapidement il était à quelques disons
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de kiev
et surtout il était à quelques dizaines
de kilomètres de kiev à la fois par le
nord par une partie de l'ouest et par
l'est et donc on se posait la question
est ce que les russes vont réussir à
prendre la capitale et donc à faire
tomber le régime craignant d'autant
qu'il y avait sept cette triple invasion
avec trois fronts et puis il y avait ça
c'était il ya plus aucun doute là dessus
il y avait par ailleurs une opération
spéciale qui était prévue à kiev avec à
la fois des des commandes aux russes qui
étaient infiltrés dans la dans la
capitale ukrainienne pour faire tomber
zelensky et puis y avait une tête de
pont
au nord ouest de kiev mais à 15 km à
l'aéroport international group de ghost
aux mails ou là il ya eu un débarquement
de troupes aéroportées les fameuses bd v
par par hélico ou papara par avion et ça
devait servir de tête de pont pour faire
le lien entre l'opération terrestre qui
arrivait par le pas par le nord de
biélorussie et avec les commandos qui
étaient directement dans dans kiev et
cette opération aéroportée qui était
très risquée agosto mail a été un
premier échec tactique même de porter
même stratégique pour la russie qui a dû
rapidement abandonner l'idée de faire
tomber le gouvernement
2nd skin ça c'était la première étape
ensuite on sait dans les premières
semaines on s'est orienté vers un siège
des grandes villes
ukrainiennes et notamment de de kiev
mais mais mais kiev pour encercler kiev
c'est une ville de quatre millions
d'habitants il fallait encerclé une un
périmètre de 150 km de diamètre en gros
c'était les ans de grandeur ça
paraissait complètement hors de portée
pour les russes et même une ville vous
voyez la deuxième ville d'ukraine c'est
kharkiv dont alès ici oui pourtant à 40
50 km de la frontière russe eh bien les
russes n'ont pas réussi kharkiv c'est
1,5 million
d'habitants et là on en revient à une
des données fondamentales s'il ya une
chose qu'il faut retenir de sur ces six
mois c'est le fait que les russes sont
arrivés en ukraine avec entre 150 et 200
mille soldats ça n'est absolument rien
pour
on verra peyo prendre un pays où même
une grande partie dans une partie d'un
pays qui est beaucoup plus grand que
l'allemagne qui est même plus lent que
la france et six cent mille kilomètres
carrés et donc on en arrive aujourd'hui
le front d'une heure n'existe plus on
sait que dès la fin du mois de mars les
russes se sont repliés à peu près en bon
ordre du front du nord ils sont
retournés en bio les russies et ils ont
été et une réorientation de la campagne
militaire vers le dombass à l'est est
aujourd'hui du côté russe les les
combats aujourd'hui
n'existe réellement que dans le bon
basse le front du sud qui avait plutôt
bien fonctionné
de par la crimée puisqu'il avait quand
même pris personne dès les premiers
jours et puis après méthodiquement ils
ont réussi à passer vous veillez à la
l'est pour établir une sorte de corridor
terrestre entre la crimée et le dombass
avec le point culminant c'était la prise
de la ville du port de marioupol qui a
duré des semaines et des semaines avec
une résistance ukrainienne qui était
très importante de ce point de vue là
c'est le seul succès russe qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il contrôle une bande de
terre
avec une continuité territoriale avec la
russie et c'est une bande de terre
qu'ils de kherson jusqu'au don base de
la crimée jusqu'en basse représente 20%
de l'ensemble du territoire ukrainien
donc ça n'est pas négligeable 20% du
territoire ukrainien ses 120 mille
kilomètres carrés c'est à peu près un
peu moins que la taille de la grèce pour
donner un ordre de grandeur mais ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'en revanche les
perspectives d'avancé russes notamment
vers l'ouest c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
les russes à carson c'est injuste après
le niet les russes ont une position
défensive ils devront le voit sur ce sur
cette carte justement alors je savais en
guinée plus de juste pour terminer plus
du tout question aujourd'hui pour les
russes
à court terme et même à moyen terme il
n'est plus du tout question de pousser
juste après dans le porno mikolaj f et
juste après dans le port d'odessa odessa
qu'à la troisième ville d'ukraine et
concrètement ça pourrait être un grand
objectif stratégique de là aussi prend
nos des sas et couper la reine d'un
accès à la mer c'est établir un contrôle
beaucoup plus fort de la russie en mer
noire et s'est reconstitué une région
historique de la de l'empiré russe qui
s'appelait la nouvelle russie la 9e rue
sia qui correspond en fait à tout le sud
de l'ukraine et qui correspond en fait
aux territoires que l'empiré russe a
pris
du xviiie jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle
surnom pas l'empiré austro hongrois mais
sur l' empire ottoman et là on ne
revient un mélange de considérations
stratégiques militaires
mais aussi à des considérations
historiques et à tous les articles au
dos de discours en déclaration de
libreville a dit me routine sur le fait
que l'ukraine n'a pas d'existence
historique entend en tant qu'etat
alors qu'aujourd'hui on voit que
effectivement il ya un certain nombre de
de gageure historique la la l'ukraine a
une une existence propre au cours de
l'histoire était extrêmement fait
puisqu'en fait est là une période
d'indépendance de 1917 à 1921 qui a été
extrêmement courte et c'était à dire
entre la fin de la première guerre
mondiale sur le front de l'est et la
révolution bolchévique et puis ensuite
son sa vraie indépendance a commencé en
1991 en tant qu'etat ils ont valsé c'est
aussi cette dimension là la guerre en
ukraine
qu'on voit aujourd'hui avec le fait
qu'il n'y a un doute qu'on n'a pas
aujourd'hui c'est que la guerre en
ukraine depuis le 24 février a fait
émerger la nation ukrainienne et ça je
pense qu'il n'y a plus de doute là
dessus
et pour vladimir poutine s'est
indubitablement un échec oui parce
qu'ils pensaient peut-être que la lqe
une partie des habitants russophiles
serait
irait côté bien sûr puisque le
bilinguisme me fait partie de l'identité
ukrainienne et c'est probablement
d'ailleurs quelque chose que les
nationalistes ukrainiens
ont parfois du mal à comprendre et
depuis très longtemps en réalité mais
sauf qu'aujourd'hui le sentiment
d'appartenance y compris chez les rushes
et léché les russophones et le ce
sentiment d'appartenance à la nation
ukrainienne il ne fait plus de doute
aujourd'hui il ya un sondage qui est
sorti il n'y a pas très longtemps il ya
91 % des ukrainiens
qui croient en la victoire possible de
l'ukraine par dans 98 % et il ya 91 %
des ukrainiens qui considèrent que le
bilan de zelensky est positif donc ça ce
sont des chiffres qui parlent en même
temps si on regarde vraiment sur le sur
le front on a aussi vu que quand les
camps les russes arrivés dans certaines
villes d'udon basse
comme si verdonnaise comme eux
comme les chances que les soldats
ukrainien à la fin nenê n'était pas
tellement accueilli en héros en héros et
au contraire les habitants locaux sur
place avaient un peu envie de leur dire
écoutez partait et on va faire que ce
soit que ce soit les russes sauf que ça
c'est les habitants qui restaient dans
cette ville est en réalité il ya eu
beaucoup de départs de population soit
vers l'ouest dans les territoires
contrôlés par l'ukraine soit pour une
bonne part aussi dans les territoires
contrôlés par l'apa par les russes donc
voilà ce qu'on voit c'est
c'est que l'on n'ait à une sorte de
point d'équilibré n'a aucune idée de
deux verres ou irhal conflit sauf
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une forme
d'enlisement militaire et une situation
politique qui est par ailleurs
complètement coincé oui alors on va
alors il ya beaucoup de questions je
salue rtf kiskun françois wolff tintin
qui sont la tintin comme indy cette
guerre qui ne devait durer que 48 heures
a mal tourné pour poutine ne peut-on pas
dire que plus qu'une défaite une déroute
pour l'armée russe non je pense qu'on
peut pas dire ça
le fait que le plan initial était un
échec c'est évident puisque aujourd'hui
a pas de doute pour dire que le plan
initial c'était de faire tomber le
gouvernement zelensky extrêmement
rapidement effectivement quelques jours
en revanche la question du temps
absolument primordiale est ce que une
guerre longue désavantage la dîmière
poutine la réalité c'est qu'on a
absolument aucune
aucun moyen de dire que oui et même
peut-être qu'une guerre longue avantage
animaux peta il est notamment sur la
question enfin celle l'ukraine est quand
même aujourd'hui un pays
en grande partie détruits sur lequel il
ya il ya des frappes de missiles de
d'artillerie tous les jours c'est un
pays qui a la foi
qui dépend complètement économiquement
et financièrement de ses soutiens
occidentaux sinon il serait clairement
en faillite et dépend aussi complètement
des soutiens occidentaux pour les
livraisons d'armements et saas etc
est ce que
on se projette dans un conflit long et
est ce que les occidentaux vont pouvoir
apporter
à l'ukraine ce soutien dans la durée on
voit qu'aujourd'hui c'est la question
essentielle en ce jeu on a vu toutes les
déclarations politiques depuis 48 heures
vont dans ce sens macron a parlé d'un
soutien de l'ukraine dans la durée les
allemands une formule similaire
chi chi un soutien aussi longtemps que
nécessaire
justement c'est la question que vous
pose sur six filles en faut-il soutenir
l'ukraine dans la durée comme le premier
manuel hommes emmanuel macron c'est la
question que vous vous posez sur le site
du figaro il y a justement du côté du
président et de toutes les forces
occidentales un réel six mois après on
continue de soutenir malgré ce que ça
coûte aux populations c'est là où il
faut distinguer le les discours
officiels ou là il ya eu effectivement
les occidentaux parlent à l'unisson et
la volonté de soutenir les ukrainiens
dans le temps long ll est là et elle est
indubitable maintenant là où il ya
certaines subtilités
c'est que par exemple emmanuel macron
dans le même temps nous annonce la fin
de l'ère de l'abondance de l'évidence
etc etc il prépare l'opinion à des mots
extrêmement difficiles et quand il dit
il prépare les français en parlant du
prix de la liberté
c'est une formule rhétorique
élégante mais mais concrètement c'est
combien le prélat liberté et on voit que
royaume uni il ya des grèves sur fond
d'inflation comme il n'y en a pas eu
depuis l'ère de margaret thatcher et en
allemagne quelque est le point central
l'allemagne de la deux
du lien historique entre la russie
l'europe et c'est pour des raisons
énergétiques politique de proximité
géographique aussi on voit que l'unité
allemande aujourd'hui
on peut dire qu'elle commence à se
fissurer les syndicats allemands mettent
en garde régulièrement le gouvernement
disant attention si on n'a plus le gaz
russe l'industrie allemande
va s'effondrer et
et socialement ça va être ça va être un
pacte extrêmement puissant et on a même
vu le vice président du bundestag
chambre routes allemandes qui appartient
au spd le parti de gauche et qui a qui
s'est prononcée plutôt pour une
ouverture du gars du gazoduc nord stream
2 ans nord stream 2 c'était en fait les
russes avaient un plan depuis longtemps
qu'ils étaient avant soutenu par
l'allemagne qui était de doubler le
gazoduc actuelle nord stream un par un
gazoduc nord stream 2 et le
gazoduc nord stream ii était quasiment
prêt à être mis en service juste avant
le début de l'invasion russe et quelques
jours après les allemands ont annoncé
le fait que ce gazoduc ne rentrerai pas
en service donc le fait qu'on reparle de
re faire entrer en service nord stream 2
ça montre bien qu'il ya une tension et
que la question du soutien ukrainien va
poser un verre quoi qu'il en coûte
doses aussi des problèmes politiques à
tous les dirigeants aussi drôle c'est la
question de françois wolff justement qui
d'un point de vue énergétique ne tombe
pas d'avoir des problèmes si la guerre
dure vraiment des problèmes on a déjà
évidemment bon déjà il ya l'inflation ça
qu en france on a 6 % d'inflation mais
parce que les prix de l'énergie sont
bloqués dans la plupart des pays
européens où il ya il n'y a pas de telle
aide le niveau de l'inflation sont
beaucoup plus élevés ils sont 10% ivoire
voir au delà ce qui aura forcément des
conséquences économiques et sociales par
ailleurs on a vu que le spectre d'une
récession
et pend au nez des pays européens on l'a
vu hier encore avec des indicateurs
industriels on a vu que le comme la
balance commerciale allemande avait été
déficitaire
ce qui n'était jamais arrivé depuis 1991
est quelqu'un avec véritable traumatisme
pour les allemands etc etc et puis
surtout la principale donnée aujourd'hui
c'est l'effondrement de l'euro ce qui
est très intéressant c'est que ce n'est
pas le rouble qui s'est effondré
aujourd'hui celui qui peut pas parler
d'effondrement mais de 2 de baisse
de 2 de baisse extrêmement significatif
c'est l'euro qui est aujourd'hui à
parité avec le dollar ce qui n'est
quasiment jamais arrivé dans l'histoire
de l'euro et donc ça c'est un impact
puisque le pétrole
notamment on l'achète en dollars et donc
si l'euro vaut moins bien notre pétrole
coûte plus cher en euros bref ça il ya
tout un tas de conséquences du coup les
européens vont devoir augmenter leurs
taux d'intérêt mais qui dit augmenter
les taux d'intérêt menace la croissance
économique celle du pib et puis par
ailleurs une augmentation des taux on a
des pays comme l'italie qui ont une
dette publique colossale et donc les
européens peuvent pas faire monter trop
les temps sinon on va se retrouver avec
une nouvelle crise dans une nouvelle
bref c'est une rentrée qui s'annonce
pour le moins extrêmement difficile et
donc quand on voit l'unanimité des
discours politiques parlant du soutien à
long terme de l'ukraine oui la volonté
politique est là maintenant concrètement
on va voir d'autant que je termine car
là on a vu aussi que le soutien
militaire des occidentaux à l'ukraine en
réalité s'est effritée ces derniers mois
il ya aujourd'hui
de livraison d'armes à l'ukraine qui a
quelques mois qui a quelques mois
notamment de la part des européens c'est
beaucoup moins le cas des américains des
américains qui sont le principal soutien
militaire
des ukrainiens bref vous voyez ça
question délicate qui au fond la
principale question c'est une guerre
longue est-ce que ça avantage la russie
ou le cannes dans une question de 2,2 de
yacine qui le demandent ne serait-il pas
temps d'essayer de trouver une issue
raisonnable à ce conflit que l'ukraine
soit en avant que l'ukraine ne sont en
ruine raisonnable voulant dire prouve
préserver l'existence d'un état
ukrainien viable alors le point mais je
pense que tout le monde le souhaiterait
mais mais mais mais sur quel terme fondé
cet accord et là on voit très bien si
vous voulez quand quand il ya une
avancée militaire qu'il ya une dynamique
militaires en général l'heure n'est pas
aux négociations
parce qu'il ya un des deux belligérants
4 aux intérêts continuent d'avancer pour
neil aussi là on est dans une situation
d'enlisement militaire qui en réalité
émerge depuis à peu près deux mois donc
les conditions de négociation sont
peut-être davantage là qu'il ya quelques
mois mais est d'ailleurs on l'a vu par
exemple avec l'accord sur les céréales
le rôle absolument centrale est
essentiel de la turquie dans le jeu des
négociations
mais malgré tout aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas envisager à court terme de
négociations politiques qui aboutissent
pourquoi parce que pour les ukrainiens
c'est inaccessible c'est d'autant plus
inaccessible qui croient c'est très
courageux c'est très valeureux il y
croit en la possibilité d'une victoire
militaire donc c'est pas maintenant
qu'ils vont négocier concrètement pour
avaliser des gains territoriaux russe
c'est impossible et par ailleurs
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui n'a pas
intérêt à négocier parce que s'il
revenait en russie en disant voilà j'ai
fait cette guerre pour ce résultat là ça
n'est pas satisfaisant et notamment on
va dire que tant qu'il ne contrôle pas
l'intégralité du dombass ce qui ne
semble pas arriver dans les jours et
semaines qui viennent parce qu'on va
montrer cette carte du des des
différentes des différents oblast l'aube
là on va reparler du donbass peu juste
pour dire que tant qu'il n'a pas
sablonnière poutine ne peut pas arriver
deux ans les russes en disant je me
passe un accord politique et donc là il
n'y a pas de possibilité d'accord
politique de négociations la situation
militaire est largement bloqués et donc
on en arrive à une conclusion sainte
c'est que la situation est extrêmement
dangereuse puisque il ya un risque réel
d'escaladé militaire notamment russes
c'est à dire qu'à la fois cette c'est
les ukrainiens qui est notamment toutes
ses frappes dans la profondeur du
dispositif wolski qui fonctionne depuis
deux mois avec les les moyens
d'artillerie notamment les les les
lance-roquettes multiples américain en
mars et voilà les les russes sont dos au
mur maintenant s'ils veulent avancer
il faut qu'ils escaladent ça veut pas
dire escalader on parle pas forcément de
nucléaire mais il faut qu'ils changent
ce dispositif militaire
252 son île homme qui ne paraît pas
correspondre aux objectifs militaires du
kremlin mais ça pose la question des
différents scénarios ce sur quoi
pourrait déboucher finalement ce conflit
absolument là pour le coup un
dispositif
constant là le scénario c'est celui d'un
gaullisme c'est qu'on voit mal sauf
on voit mal les russes avançait dans le
donbass où les ukrainiens réellement
avancer en crimée parce que ce que la
plupart des spécialistes militaires
disent c'est que l'offensive la
contre-offensive ukrainienne dans la
région de kherson
à ce jour elle paraît peu probable pour
plein de pour plein de raisons
peut-être qu'ils vont continuer à
exercer une pression très forte sur
quatre personnes peut-être qu'ils vont
avancer un peu mais on l'est on les
imagine mal
aller au delà du nlhe après même déjà
prendre le nième ça serait déjà un
énorme avancée militaire
parce que l'alarmé ukrainienne faut bien
voir que pour elle le principal enjeu
d'un point de vue militaire
c'est évidemment elle a sonné la
mobilisation générale donc allen pour le
coup contrairement à la russie elle a
une masse d'hommes théorique
considérable mais en revanche des hommes
il faut les former ça ça prend du temps
ça coûte de l'argent et après il ya la
question du matériel or depuis le 24
février on parle énormément d armement
occidentaux ont été fournies à l'ukraine
on se souvient déjà des missiles javelin
des etc etc aujourd'hui des détails mars
et enfin la
quasi-totalité de l'armement
ukrainiens c'est un armement soviétique
qui datent de du bloc soviétique or
aujourd'hui l'ukraine en la matière fait
face à des risques de pénurie
considérable et ils ne peuvent pas se
réapprovisionner par exemple en haut
vues de type soviétique c'est donc au
vert il faut qu'il change de système
avec des systèmes occidentaux et ça
c'est une gageure considérable surtout
s'ils doivent augmenter leur masse pour
non plus défendre résisté mais aller à
l'offensive et et avancer on a beau
vivre dans les commentaires qui me
demandent pour effet par effet de
symétrie le risque n'est-il pas que
poutine fasse comme les les états unis
lors de la seconde guerre mondiale quand
ils ont utilisé une bombe pour stopper
la guerre
est-ce que la menace nucléaire est à
prendre au sérieux on va dire il faut
toujours pour la menace aussi la menace
tout client au sérieux puisque la
dissuasion nucléaire
fait partie de la grammaire
stratégique militaire de notre
notre époque et ça fait ça fait
longtemps
une escalade nucléaire c'est à dire
aujourd'hui que dieu merci elle est très
improbable il ya les questions de l'usaj
du ce qu'on appelle le nucléaire
tactique c'est à dire d'une arme
nucléaire beaucoup plus petite que les
armes stratégiques ma fac m en général
plus grosse que hiroshi plus puissante
qu'hiroshima sonné gaza qui est qui est
employé dans le cadre du champ de
bataille
pour l'instant franchement heureusement
on n'en est pas là c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on peut exclure et là on peut
reparler des scénarios par exemple c'est
à dire que aujourd'hui ce qui est
intéressant dans le discours ukrainien
c'est qu'ils veulent reprendre
l'intégralité du territoire ukrainien
dans ses frontières de 1991 c'est à dire
crime est comprise
or la crimée fait partie
officiellement du point de vue russe du
territoire russe donc si les ukrainiens
mettre un pied en crimée la russie peut
dire que ses intérêts vitaux sont
atteints hélas si ce jour-là arriver
encore une fois militairement on en est
très loin mais si ce jour-là arriver on
changerait complètement de d'échelle et
là pour le coup on risquerait une
escalade d'escala nucléaire
effectivement on a eu scène al-mahdi qui
demande l'ukraine peut-elle obtenir par
une négociation ce qu'elle n'a pas pu
récupérer par la guerre c'est ce qu'on
dit tout à l'heure sur négociations non
pour la raison qu'on a dit c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les conditions de
possibilité de négociations politiques
ne sont pas réellement là parce que
l'objectif des ukrainiens c'est une
victoire largement total et du côté
russe ils ont besoin
d'un minimum de deux réussites
territoriales qui ne sont pas là non
plus et notamment commencer par le
nombre ils adorent et son intégralité
est une question dont on a parlé aussi
la petite info qui nous demandent n'y at
il pas un risque de lassitude des pays
alliés eux-mêmes bientôt priorité par
une crise énergétique c'est une
c'est un très gros risque j'ai envie de
dire que c'est le principal risque pour
zelensky on a lancé une série
dt au figaro ce dont six jours sur le le
conflit l'ukrainien est le troisième
épisode là c'était comment zelensky est
devenu un chef de guerre et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui personne
ne peut renier le fait que zelensky
cette affaire affirmé comme comme un
chef de guerre la question pour lui
maintenant c'est plutôt comment il faut
le rester et c'est ça qui est le plus
délicat on a vu ce qu'on observe dans
tous les conflits mais pas qui est
particulièrement flagrant avec l'ukraine
un désintérêt
soudain et massif pour la question
ukrainienne on le voit dans les
requêtes de google on le voit sur les
dents les datas des des réseaux sociaux
et cetera et cetera et ce désintérêt des
occidentaux combinée à l'impact de la
guerre sur
la vie économique et sociale des pays
occidentaux
et un danger réel danger pour vous le
dis merci lenski oui alors l'article
dont vous parliez six mois de conflit en
ukraine et ce qui reste à la figure du
chef de guerre qui est accessible sur le
site du figaro que vous pouvez aller
lire je voulais vous montrer aussi cette
question du jour dont on a parlé en
début de live c'est celle ci alors
attendez je vais vous l'actualiser que
c'était déjà pas mal de gens qui ont
voté 12000 personnes qui ont voté et on
voit que les lecteurs du figaro sont
assez partagés sur la question
cinquante-sept pour cent l'action et il
faut quand même un oui massif c'est ça
ma 57% sequi l'homme bon bah je sais pas
gagné encore de votants alors nous avons
les seahawks et souvent on est en train
d'être treize mille votants dont on est
encore au début du vote a passé avec
woods n'a pas valeur de sondage bien sûr
bien évidemment dont aucune valeur
scientifique mais ce sera ça sera très
intéressant de voir les sondages dans
les jours qui viennent
et notamment entre les pays des
différents pays européens et ça risque
d'évoluer énormément au fur et à mesure
que la la crise énergétique deviendra de
plus en plus graves effectivement merci
beaucoup en tout cas lexsi d'avoir été
avec merci aujourd'hui je remercie
également le service infographie du
figaro qui a été présent pour nous
fournir ses cartes que vous avez pu voir
que je vais vous remonterez ici je
remercie également semaines varient pour
la modération des commentaires
merci beaucoup merci à vous lecteurs du
figaro d'avoir été très nombreux et on
va arrêter ce live d'ici quelques
vérités se lie puisque un autre
événement
va se passer bientôt celle pour la
rentrée du conseil des ministres vous
pouvez le voir le pupitre est présent
ici on parlera politique et ce sera
thibault gauthier qui sera avec dina
cohen dans quelques instants où paradent
tout ça donc rester avec nous et à 17h30
on reparlera évidemment de la question
du jour quand on vous a parlé et ce sera
donc à 17h30 comme vous lisez et moi je
vous dis à bientôt pour de nouveaux
lives sur figaro relève